mais c'est pour qui les martinets bah
les chiens les belles-mères votre mari
peut-être oui pour Charles 85 ans c'est
l'heure de la livraison ah le
voilà quelques bouteilles de sirop à
l'ancienne l'une de ces nombreuses
spécialités bonjour
Voilà oui voilà Martinet mais
Martinet
11 12
mais c'est pour qui les martinets bah
les chiens les belles-mères votre mari
peut-être c'est un myth pour cambR je
pense que pourquoi bah il est connu
partout on vient de loin pour le voir le
neuf rue Pasteur à Cambray n'a pas
changé depuis 54 ans Charles Marlière
écrit toujours ses prix à la main
n'oublie jamais le petit cadeau au
livreur des sardines je vous remerci ni
son sens commerçant ça c'est l'éamine
une Hamine ça c'est dans les fermes pour
égûter le fromage blanc du temps qu' des
petites fermes on peut faire du canva on
peut faire beaucoup de choses et et pour
faire les gelettes grosill framboise
tout ça ceux qui font encore vous en
vendez encore oui mais de moins en moins
parce que les jeunes ils font plus ils
achètent des Trites tout
fait des étamines des à souris
et même de l'autobrasseur pour fabriquer
sa propre bière Charles n'a jamais
quitté ses étales même à moitié vide ni
ses souvenirs
jeux pas
pour
TER
que de
an n pas le dernierot GR à
btis
toujoursentle
toutes les bêtises de cambré se
retrouvent ici il y a de jolies boîtes
il y a tout il y a tous les choix et je
vous dis il y a une odeur il y a il y a
quelque chose qui n'existe plus ailleurs
en tout cas certainement pas dans les
grandes surfaces et puis il y a un
contact toujours un
vrai un contact que Charles apprécie
tout particulièrement avec la clientèle
[Musique]
féminine vous avez un homme un homme ou
j'en ai plus plus
qu'un oui beaucoup
gigotter donc vousavez plus
d'acné je suis atypique atypique c'est
ce qu'il a dit mon
cousin mon cousin je
atypique le mot
atypiqueend jamais parler de ce motl
[Musique]
atypique